[Musique]
ouais
pourquoi tu vas te voir ici la traque
est toujours en cours pour retrouver
l'animal qui aurait été vu dans les
environs après s'être échappée de
l'airport orly
des batteurs
d'avant
cet animal sauvage cet animal est
dangereuse surtout ne l'approchez pas
alors que suite appelé si tu pensé à
king
sorte mais sûrement
on va aller voir mon grand père je suis
sûr qu'il pourra nous aider nous idée à
quoi
le mari qu elle est complètement tard il
met d'accord
il a fait 10 fois le tour du monde
laissera quoi faire
max j'ai besoin de votre aide
tu sais king
je ramène chez lui
c'est dans deux mois il fera le double
de sa taille et de son poids
à ce carillon maintenant plus bosser ça
reste
je vais pas tarder à les retrouver
accélère ralentit moi je vous ralentir
attention
est ce que tu sais ce qu'ils vont lui
faire c'est la trappe
tu pourras pas à côté je vais toujours
être toujours
[Musique]
voyagez pas remis